tanta tanta tata tata ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta dead
eye fi qualcosa di forzuto la data
perfetto ciao ragazzi siamo io e
quest'uomo praticamente vi spiego questa
cosa e fighissima sì l'ho scoperta io
tra le quindi devi morire chi sono
questi 1 esko ion venisse già rotto le
balle giocare la trail che a questi
quella che hanno fatto le cose bene sono
tutti i più belli di te
vi spiego ragazzi che cos'è allora lo
vedete quella torre grossa lì è uscita
dal culo si scherza per niente dobbiamo
arrivare in cima
ecco è questo bisogna bisogna arrivare
in cima alla torre bisogna fare parkour
perché non è facile salire su questa
torre e arrivare in cima su sei carico
tipica di chi si vede dallo sguardo ore
21 via che bella è stato incredibile
come la chiamiamo questa serie scala la
torre o chiamiamo per stare lontano da
te scale ray questa montagna non so in
qualche modo dovremmo chiamarla st lepri
fighissimo punti d'oro
io già sto facendo fatica ad arrivare
smith e liquami web e che quel pover sto
facendo fatica ok premi primi premi
primi questo caso questo pavic è una
presso il play sicuro che di muovere
così non avrei qui l'obiettivo arrivare
sopra aver mai semplice finora ma che
questo tutorial quindi penso e qui amico
a ok ho capito no no no no non ascolta
ascolta ascolta lo hai visto quanto è
grosso alla torre nostra tv se inizi a
fare così io ti giuro che katy stermino
la stirpe no te lo giuro
ti faccio male a tutti gli avi allora
aspetta grado di sopra un attimo ok ma
come hai fatto a fare sta roba scusa se
va beh ma sei scemo sei pazzo e ce l'ha
fatta è stato ma fammi fammi capire una
cosa è figura di fammi capire una cosa
ma se io tremo la presso plate poi
riparto da quasi caso propria forma cosa
no no no no no se tu puoi fare
no no no no vedi che sei stupido una
barca di quella di quella niente niente
di dio
no veramente ti faccio male te lo giuro
va bene il tacco le braille vai avanti
ok andiamo avanti
aspetta c'ero quasi riuscito a seguito
di quanto credessi è nata non ci sono
riuscito tu sei stai fermo come fatto se
come hai fatto a salire la sopra
impossibile o perfetto perfetto vai vai
vai vai vai suo carico per il mondo
allora perché su minecraft non c'è la
corsa come in tutti i giochi ma devi
schiacciare due volte il tasto w nonché
problemi a match contro da percorrere io
non lo sapevo dove giuro
veramente non si può mai sta cosa
niente non risco gara difficile
disegnare sul blocco esatto e saltare
alla tua sinistra
ok perfetto per fermarti supero vai
carico guardali speedrun speedrun
fortissimo
ciao pietro ciao pietro ciao ciao ci
vediamo alla prossima al prossimo video
non è così ma è così vado avanti mi
proprio felicissimo velocissimo non
cadere mai pietro di rimanere lì per
dente ok ok fortissimo ciao amico come
si può questo ciao amico ciao
non so dove sta andando mi sono sentito
fortissimo per un attimo cos'è sta roba
questi tentacoli stranger things lega
che figo è bruttissimo però ok che
fenomeno che fenomeno di fano guardalo
io dico adesso è non è per noi sono
caduto dal male
peccato non ci avresti mai fatta fare
sta cosa
e anch'io sono casa anche se anche
sottolinea sei caduto giù la vita è
bella
grazie dio esiste cosa devo fare guarda
che non devi fare quello che stanno
facendo prima
ok scherzo devi fare quello che stanno
facendo prima ok è l'ultimo salto e
quello che non riuscirò a fare sgomenti
sì sì sì ce l'ha fatta
oddio no cos'è sta roba ciao amico si
sta roba qua fai vedere è bello questo
salto e visto che bravo come si fa ma è
una specie di trampolino è un gioco di
sliven ma si andrà un pò in ombra di
come mai non è giusto ed eventi da più
spinta più slancio hanno fatto saltare
te mentre invece che sulla scala
sull'altro farsi averi brutto pirla
beh va beh ci serve dopo quello arco
demonio cosa ho fatto
bravi lo sono anche come ho fatto prove
di che sono stupido nell'anima della
vita della morte porca eva intrisa nel
sangue il tipo specie il momento secondo
prima non è non è poco tanto di premier
la lega n ma devo tenerlo premuto il
tasto no spettava perfetto ma se non
riusciamo a fare neanche questo come
speri fare quello dopo un secondo prima
o poi tanto prima di premere lo sa ma va
a cagare
adesso sto andato oltre capito bravo
pietro ma ho beccato la scala perché te
la scalata è stato dato lo scalo ha
destato soli di orta dai anch'io da dove
si è caduto dalla sopra porca vacca
tanta è stata la scala è fatta
maledizione anche un pietrone incatenato
gli autobus spetta è fortissimo bravo
pietro dove devo andare così che aiuto
poi si fa qualche ce l'ha fatta
ce l'avevo fatta ce l'ho fatta non ci
posso credere che io ho fatto così
guardi no ma che non ce la farò mai più
poi non stare lì non ti guarda tutti
metti lì sopra io ti ammazzo tutta la
famiglia ti ammazzo il gatto muovi ti
devi togliere dalle palle noi non
salterò mai non ti mettere più saremo
soli dettagliato di saltare ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta ce
l'ho fatta
non ci credo non so come però ce l'ho
fatta ma provarci l'ultima volta
vai pietro vediamo se riesci insegnato
tu a farcela bravo pietro bravo pietro
così di fare così è da qui che ho fatto
fatto fatto da palo o un comico aspetta
ok comunque a tenere il tasto contro mi
sta venendo un crampo fortissimo al dito
e dov'ero io ti aspetto qui voglio
vedere cosa fai della tua vita adesso
voglio vederti schiantato invece
attenzione no non è vero da sé che
persone inutile che sei cosa doveva fare
quando manca il carrello o ok arrivato
qua sopra
di fatto era saltata dove saltato forte
non so se sta servendo cui magari usando
il kart per niente bene amico ce lo fa
quando sono saltato dei satiri senato
dove sara il corpo e non lo so non
chiedermi cosa serviva il kart e
probabilmente la solo per bellezza per
rompere le palle basse e gli effetti di
tipo distrarre
praticamente se io ho fatto anche quello
dopo crisi e divertenti questa davanti e
ti lasci indietro
grazie no mi sono beccato amico gli
scampati altissimo aiuta a ok a posto mi
ha fatto un giro della spirale quasi
attenzione che sono stati difficilissimi
da fare risaltare 5 1 2 3 4 5 blocchi è
saltato
poi vedi porca eva non riesco a frenare
di un ora che ci provo è riuscito subito
mi sono sentito come se questo è
semplice quello di prima non era
semplice ok ok amico
aiutami ci sarà sicuramente un pezzo
dell'albero 2 salire ai giovani non lo
so mi guarda tutto nuovo
maria e non lo sanno l'avevo vista mai
nella vita figurare anch'io ho ben
capito dove cavolo arriviamo siamo
arrivati davanti alla madonna se abbiamo
fatto di strada in salita incredibile ci
siamo anche accorti
ok non è vero nel mondo del pianeta
terra
ciao come hai fatto il karma rega ciao
amico ci si mette scherzavo perché mi
mancava in un modo per non dire gatto se
non con somiglia pietro ricorda te vieni
qua va dai ragazzi siamo riusciti
arrivare fino qua a discapito di pietro
se riuscissi a fare tutto io sto gioco
ed anche perché non penso di aver
bisogno di quell'uomo di quell'essere
voglio solo vederti cadere solo per
questo sto guardando che scherzavo non
devi andare avanti la devi venire quadri
di andarlo a giovedì laggiù dove qui no
porca vacca hai capito però lasciato
maria ma non sull'ex sul campo lo so che
ti piace prendere i cactus nel deretano
ma non è questo il caso serve adesso è
forse sì se perché se c'hai ragione sai
bravo no già fatta ci ho fatto l'ho
fatta sì sì sì e non mi chiede come non
ci ho fatto aspettare o ho fatto chi
vuole dopo ora salta subito dopo voglio
vederti qua o cribbio mai provaci
bravissimo questa difficile e bravo ok
come potrebbe esserci un paese altamente
vabbè finché la iaaf ha colto aspettare
ma arriva da amazon prime ore culo come
fate a fa sta roba
butti mezzo ti nell'avere fino a qua ma
tenuti nel water
ma poi schifo ma togliti dalle balle
ciao amico ciriano no se ti chiami ha
colpito cosa vuoi da la mia vita il
karma esattamente in che stato ri fi
avrà tutto questo pezzo di questo albero
no non ho capito come cosa vuoi fare
amiche ma da ieri soddisfatta su quello
non lo vedevo neanche che vi sembran
dito medio te lo giuro tutto per te
guarda bello in primis volevo livello
tranquillo una rottura di balle vai
entrati dopo la porta che figata sono
entrati in un cos'è una casa non detta
carina maya ma io mi sa che acqua che
vado
magari insieme no per ora va bene devi
fare dal piccolo di passare a quello più
medio non credo si possa fare così che
pirla ok ma non vale
ma cosa non vale fatto che si gioca non
esclusivamente questa sul caso un
bravissimo era ok claro grazie ad grado
dove si fa perché questo più facile divo
alternano livelli possibili di semplice
quindi si è più facile vipers che sono
anche dove sto andando
io sto salendo sugli alberi micam anche
una scimmia perché quindi evitare il
blocco preciso sta cosa mi mette ansia
ogni volta blocco preciso per salvarti
culo è veramente diventano as
incredibile ogni volta devo fare un
salto perché ci dovrei arrivare li vedi
che non ci arrivano haga n
cosa devo fare ce l'ho fatta dio mio
si vabbè ci ho messo un'ora ma ce l'ho
fatta
ok
ok non so che qui dove si può andarti a
brutti sti alberi
cosi brunetta aspetta che ansa che ne
pensa che mettono si slime schifosi ma
come fai a non saper fare lo zucchero a
cagata e un tutorial quelli in confronto
orco di razza netco baby medio baby non
ci provare mai più
dobbiamo dimostrare la scala la cascata
come scusa mi dicevi loro scala scala
cioè nota fa qualcosa di mio
no l'ho fatto io come hai usato la
cascata per andare su la linfa lima che
pirla
ho capito thank you my friend volevi di
la verità volevi buttarmi giù perché no
ero cellulare io di lavorare io pensavo
che pensavo che avessi fatto unmis
incredibile della serie mai mancato
allora ero convinto che mi avessi
mancato perché l'ho buttato giù non lo
so perché e vabbè qua e qua ci
divertiamo ci raccontiamo le storie devi
saltare sull'altro albero questo davanti
però di trovare il modo giusto
come fai c'è l'albero che ti diremo
bravo mai fatto come già fa allora è
vero come mickey infatti impossibile
stata già fatta
perciò non so come fatto come fatto
avanti anche scopo era difficile ma
abbiamo fatto bene
di nuovo avanti da essi gaza ma da marco
ma dai
pertanto non si è capaci aspetta che ma
ho messo la faccia salire qua come
quando circa parte del problema no
aspetta così la che aiuto devono aver
capito forse sì si sia capito
let's go baby let's fucking o brevi
ciapa no ma ancora lì sei sai tu vai
adesso sulle stagionate pensata sul
pillolo sopra stavolta come cazzo hai
fatto a capirlo lo so è usato per bello
ma sei capace non sei capace
[Musica]
ho usato le cervella
quindi ragazzi per oggi concluso più il
primo episodio della spirale gigante
grossa e spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto mi piace del casinò e fate che
alcune parti sono snervanti da fare meno
male che taglio perché ci sono dei pad
elevati in cui lancio è veramente del
mouse e la tastiera però solo queste
amiche ciao pietro
detto fatto avrà bravo complimenti cosa
facciamo
da qualche tempo nel presente i giochi
sono ok becchiamo abbastanza unica o che
sia piaciuto ti piace questo si chiede
ora ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video da
ragazzi
[Musica]